TV has come a long way since its conception.
Original programing is now competing with
big blockbuster films in terms of budgets
and fandoms.
Despite the amazing cast and crews behind
some of these hit television shows, the occasional
mistake can slip by without anyone noticing
until it’s too late.
Give us a like if you never noticed these
10 mistakes in big TV shows!
Friends
In the episode “the one where Ross finds
out”, Rachel learns that Ross and Julie
are going to be getting a cat.
Between the shots however, something vanished
and reappeared without the crew noticing.
In one shot, Rachel can be seen without a
necklace yet after the action returns to her,
she is without said necklace.
Cut back to her and she has magically produced
a necklace only to have it missing again in
her next shot.
The Simpsons
Fun fact: continuity errors can even make
their way into animation, even one of the
most popular animated programs of all time.
In the very first Simpsons episode “Christmas
special: Simpsons roasting on an open fire”,
Bart, Millhouse and Lewis can be seen on the
balcony leaning in looking at the mall Santa
(who just happens to be Homer).
When Bart leaves, the cut shows Millhouse
and Lewis, who has unexpectedly changed races
from African American to Caucasian.
How I met your mother
It happens on a TV series that runs for seasons
on end that the writers may end up forgetting
the smallest details that they mentioned years
ago.
This was the case on How I met your mother,
where it was stated in season 5 that Lily
and Marshall have been using the same toothbrush
ever since they’ve been together.
Yet in the season 1 episode “zip zip zip,”
Lily and Marshall are shown brushing their
teeth with individual toothbrushes.
Game of Thrones
Game of Thrones is arguably one of the biggest
and greatest TV shows to have ever been produced.
Despite its monster production costs, even
the occasional mistake will inevitably slip
its way into the final product.
Case in point the episode titled “The Pointy
End”.
Eagled eyed fans will noticed that ironically,
there is a Kingsguard on the right side of
the frame in the red keep trying very hard
without much success to sheath his sword.
It’s with the pointy end man.
Gilmore Girls
Fans rejoiced when Netflix revealed the beloved
show would return on their network, causing
immediate binges of the previous season to
fuel their excitement.
But did anyone notice the continuity error
in the episode “red light on the wedding
night”?
At Luke’s place, Lorelai, Rory and Max are
all having breakfast and having some coffee
to go with.
Look closely and you’ll notice that the
coffee cups go from red to blue between shots.
Also worth pointing out that Max’s coffee
cup likes to travel across the table, going
from the left side to the right side of his
placemat.
Family guy
Sometimes artists and directors come up with
multiple shot designs to choice from in the
final cut but might accidently mix up those
concepts in the final cut.
This is evident in the Family Guy episode
“and the wiener is” when Peter is driving
down the road to the tunnel.
In three different shots, the white painted
lines on the road go from broken to totally
gone to being a solid straight line.
Buffy the vampire slayer
Who’s that person there?
Every now and again, both in film and on television,
the action may get frantic enough that it
just gets too demanding for the crew to micromanage
every meticulous detail.
This happened in the fifth season of Buffy
the Vampire Slayer, in the episode “This
Year’s Girl” when Buffy and Faith got
into a fight and tumbled down the stairs.
In the initial runs of the episode, the camera
man responsible for the following reaction
shot can actually be seen in frame to the
left of the staircase.
Got a little too close their buddy!
Game of Thrones
Episode 9 of any season of Game of Thrones
is known to be the big one, where the chances
of character deaths or major revelations come
to light.
Perhaps with all the action going on we as
fans failed to notice a huge chance for Danerys
between the events of episode 9 and 10.
In the amphitheatre during the coordinated
attack by the sons of harpy, Dany can be seen
wearing a long elegant white gown yet in the
following episode, dirt aside, we can tell
Dany is wearing a slightly different outfit
that isn’t as regal or as long as per previous
dress.
Other modifications include her shoulder pieces
and the visibility of her boots.
I guess she has a secret stash of clothes
just hiding out in Essos.
Breaking Bad
Considered to be one of the greatest shows
ever made, Breaking Bad can be excused when
it makes an error.
The show was known for tossing in pop culture
and news events into its narrative but creator
Vince Gilligan jumped the gun in the fifth
season when the death of Osama bin Laden was
pointed out almost a year too early as the
show’s timetable put the fifth season in
2010, while bin Laden was killed in 2011.
Gilligan would later admit to his mistake,
but since this is Breaking Bad, we can let
this one go.
Westworld
The monster hit debut of 2016, Westworld flooded
the internet with crazy theories and appreciation
for weeks.
While everyone was debating what could and
could not be real, they may have noticed a
few mistakes slip through the cracks.
Westworld wasted no time in this matter, having
a continuity error slip past us in the first
episode.
When Evan Rachel Wood’s Delores emerges
from the shop across the street from Maeve’s,
we see two gentlemen standing right next to
her.
A quick reaction shot to Teddy is shown before
the action cuts back to Delores, only this
time; she is now in the presence of a single
gentleman with a tophat.
There really is a glitch in the matrix!
Those are our picks for the 10 mistakes in
big tv shows you never noticed.
Do you agree with our list?
What other crazy mistakes have you noticed
in your favourite tv series?
Whatever they are, let us know in the comments
and don’t forget to subscribe for more videos
like this one!